the heart of drama in any
movie is a reversal basically you think
something's gone one way and suddenly
everything changes i really i spend
i spend the first big chunk of time just
working
in little notebooks and all i do is i
draw like arcs
and split them out into like sequences i
need to basically be able to see the
whole
plot in my head before i can sit down
and actually start writing
you shouldn't write dialogue until
until you're you until your characters
in your head are
literally bursting with word you should
your problem should be that
keeping up with the words as you're
typing the notion of like look over here
while you're actually
you know slipping a card in their pocket
or sending something else up here
the way that usually works the best is
when it's emotional misdirection you
know that you've pulled off a great plot
twist when it feels satisfying
beyond just oh that reaction when you
actually feel like people are happy
that it has happened after it's done it
feels like it was inevitable even though
they didn't see it coming
the heart of drama in any
movie is a reversal basically you think
something's gone one way and suddenly
everything changes
a plot twist is to something in the
movie that is a
big hinge moment that you don't see
coming and i think it's not effective
when it feels like it comes out of
nowhere and is disconnected from what
came before it whereas
if it feels like the culmination of
something or if it's a surprise but it's
a surprise and it connects up with
things
from earlier in the movie then it feels
satisfying to an audience you shouldn't
write dialogue until
until you're you until your characters
in your head are
literally bursting with work you should
your problem should be that
keeping up with the words as you're
typing and for me the way that that
happens is it's the very last step of
the process
that structure is is not just kind of
mechanical story structure
it's character motivation what you're
really doing with structure is figuring
out whose perspective you're
talking from what each of these
characters wants in each one of these
scenes and how that's guiding us through
it
so that when you sit down to write the
words you
know in every specific scene what each
character
wants in that scene and
that then is is gives you kind of that
foundation
and then you can just let them talk in
your head then you can just become a
crazy person and let these voices out
and and in terms of like the specific
voices and how they talk and everything
it's i yeah again i don't know just for
me it's it's nothing
less crazy than just literally letting
them talk and transcribing it you just
kind of have to create
create them in your head and then when
their voice sounds right you kind of
know it but i wasn't just thinking of
the cityscape i'm thinking
it's the entire tonally it's a very
complicated
thing yeah yeah and you keep it just to
the point where it's going to confuse
the audience and then
but enough so they can figure it out
well that yeah i mean that's a
storyteller
that's yeah that's absolutely uh i mean
i wanted it to
you know anytime you're dealing with
time travel you're mixing a really
complicated thing into the
into the soup and so much of your work
as a writer ends up going into
taming that element of it and especially
with this movie because it was i didn't
want to be a puzzle movie i didn't want
to be something where
the audience felt like they were doing
algebra homework watching it i wanted
them to i wanted to be a ride not a
puzzle
and also i wanted to get to a very
emotional place at the end so
um it was important that the time travel
did its job and then kind of took a
backseat and let these characters deal
with the situation
um so yeah that was something that i
mean a lot of the elbow grease and the
writing went into
trying to pull that off it's obviously
um
behind it's the ghost of agatha christie
why particularly that now
well i've been an agatha christie fan
since i was a kid i've been reading her
books all my life
and i'm a big fan of the um of
all who done at movies but particularly
for me the ones where
peter yustenov played poirot which were
in the kind of late 70s early 80s
the sweet spot was death on the nile and
evil under the sun and um
that kind of all-star cast
and not a comedy not a parody like a
straightforward mystery but with a sense
of
slightly cheeky self-aware fun
and then yeah the notion of really
genuinely
taking a whodunnit and trying to plug it
into
2019 um not just by giving it kind of a
modern scan and putting cell phones
phones in it but doing kind of trying to
do what agatha christie did with her
characters which were um
you know they seem like kind of dusty
old tropes today
the all of her character types like the
you know gruff old colonel and the
butler and but when she was writing
those were
she was drawing kind of you know
elevated kind of caricature-like
versions of types who were very present
in
her contemporary society and the idea of
doing that
today um doing a whodunit where we do
the same thing and kind of draw these
big
larger in the life characters but for
maybe some people that we'd recognize a
little more in
in 2019 for better and for worse
i like the relationship between telling
a story on the screen and a card trick
i'm always really interested by that
analogy because there
there are a lot of similar elements that
are at play and one of the big ones is
is misdirection the notion of like look
over here while you're actually
you know slipping a card in their pocket
or sending something else up here
the way that usually works the best is
when it's emotional misdirection
basically when you're guiding the
audience emotionally to feel a certain
way
and that's going to bias them to looking
at things from a certain angle
while the thing that you're actually
setting up is in the other direction
that's always i think the most effective
thing
inglorious bastards you don't think of
really as a plot twist movie but
maybe the number one example of a thing
that happened at the end of a movie that
i didn't expect when i felt as if i was
floating off of my seat in the theater
with the realization of oh my god this
is what this movie is doing the fact
that we know it's a
here's a gang that's going to try and
kill hitler movie and so from the very
start
all of our expectations emotional and
otherwise
are tuned towards tragedy because no
one's going to kill hitler we know
they're not and so
these guys are going to fail because of
that that's the ultimate misdirection
so at the end of it when you're waiting
for it all to go
go wrong and it does all start going
wrong it happens
and they win and i remember when i
realized i was watching
a fantasy i remember that having
the emotional effect on me that i think
is the
ultimate thing that any plot twist could
ever aim for
which is a feeling of revelation you
feel like the floodgates have opened in
your heart
and like oh my god this is what this is
actually doing and
that for me exemplifies the emotional
reaction that the best plot twist can
give you
some advice on screenwriting um i
i mean i think it's one thing that i
kind of want to start doing more of is
is
getting a hold of scripts from movies
that i love
and reading them reading the original
script and it's really important to
track down
if you can the shooting script as
opposed to one that's been conformed to
the movie
because you're going to learn a lot from
just hearing the writer's voice seeing
how the writer engages the reader on the
page
and seeing how they pull you through the
narrative the other thing though
that i always find really helpful is to
do the exact opposite as well
is to look at a movie that you love and
i actually i put like the counter on
when i'm watching it i'll sit with a
notepad
and mark down when the major events
happen
in time and kind of diagram out the film
and it's really fascinating with some of
your favorite films if you do that
it's almost like opening the back of a
watch you kind of suddenly
see you see through the matrix and you
can kind of see structurally how the
thing
ticks and why all the things happen when
they happen
um very structural things to do but it's
one element that i find really useful
like i'm curious so on day one you're
sitting down to write this thing
how much do you know the entire arc how
much are you can you sort of talk about
because
it's it's all about figuring out where
to give information and
there's so many little things yeah well
i i mean with
every script and with this one in
particular i write really structurally
i have to start um i really i spend i
spend
this the first big chunk of time just
working in
little notebooks and all i do is i draw
like arcs and split them out into like
sequences
i need to basically be able to see the
whole plot in my head before i can sit
down and actually start writing or i'll
get lost in the weeds
um so i planned and planned and planned
and planned and this was
like that only more so this was even
more crucial for me to have the whole
thing mapped out
but then you actually get into it and as
you guys who are writers you know you
get into it no matter how much you plan
you know it's it's like you you plan out
your map through the forest looking at
like the map and
in your cozy living room and then you
get in there and you're actually hacking
through the forest and you figure out
stuff doesn't work and
you figure out new paths and so yeah
it's kind of a mixture i guess
you know that you've pulled off a great
plot twist when it feels satisfying
beyond just oh that reaction when you
actually feel like
people are happy that it has happened
after it's done it feels like it was
inevitable even though they didn't see
it coming
that's some heavy duty conjecture plot
twists in my movies again i try and make
it so that they're never really the
point like with knives out for example
it has a revelation at the end in terms
of a whodunit style revolution
for me it's much more about the
relationship that has
to the character of martha's arc
throughout the story and how you're
going to react to
the very last shot of the movie
basically to me that's kind of the
actual twist that i'm
doing with the audience is where she
ends up at the end of the film
in relation to the family yeah and
similar with brick like i mentioned
there's the plot twist of oh it was
actually
the femme fatale the whole time but the
real plot twist for me is what she
tells him at the very end that
completely shifts your emotional
perspective
the stuff i'm always going for and
trying to give people an experience of
is kind of an emotional revelation as
opposed to
um you know a true plot twist i don't
know is it gonna sound
sound like something you put on like an
inspirational poster or something but
you do just have to find
you gotta just make you gotta find your
voice and follow it you get you gotta
and
that sounds like so cheeseball and
completely just in the clouds but
the reality is is also the most
practical and useful advice that i can
imagine because the most precious
commodity if you want to use that word
in the industry
is a unique talented voice and
as much as there is reason to be cynical
about the industry and about
it's the tough it is and all the sharks
in it all the motivations the reality is
if you got
something to say and you can say it well
people will it's not necessarily that
you'll like i don't know nothing's
guaranteed or whatever
but that is something that everybody is
looking
for it's something that sounds very kind
of
high in the sky but it is actually the
best
advice is don't think strategically in
terms of how do i break in
just focus inward focus on what do i
have to say
how do i care most about saying it and
then do the work and get it out there
any way you can
and then i had the script i had this
very weird script
and i had no connections at all in
hollywood
i had very few social skills and so
it i had no idea how to go about getting
it made and so basically what i did
was just try to get the script literally
anybody who would who would read it you
know and
forget agents managers producers i'm
talking like anybody who would
who would read it essentially you know
but i guess what i'm saying is though
it's you can't be too selective and you
can't be too precious in terms of
you can't and you i don't think it's
even that useful to try and like
think out and target okay this person
that person i think it
really the shotgun approach is what what
worked for us because the truth is you
never know
who you're going to give it to who might
like it and who might give
it to who who might give it to who who
might give it to who there's no way to
predict like the chain reaction that's
gonna get it to someone who will
actually be useful um
so i mean if your neighbor is willing to
read it give it to your neighbor because
who knows
who your neighbor knows you know it's
you